time is a fundamental quantity which
humans have always been interested in
and we use it to define the duration of
events and the separation between them
now in order to make sense of time we as
humans use clocks and we have defined
units of time like the second or the
hour but the problem when thinking about
time as we know it in terms of clocks
that we use is that the clocks we use in
everyday life are actually really quite
complicated and they don't keep very
precise time in order to gain some
further understanding about what time is
fundamentally we have to use the
simplest kind of clock imaginable now to
design a clock what you use is something
which stays constant over time in order
to define a constant unit of time we
tend to use a physical constant now
historically like you would find in a
grandfather clock say this would be the
period of a pendulum swinging but we're
going to use instead in our simple clock
is something much much more fundamental
to the universe the speed of light to
define our clock we use a very simple
piece of physics we use the fact that
the distance traveled by an object
moving at speed V is equal to that speed
multiplied by the time that we observe
it for in other words the x equals V
times T the basic idea for our clock
then is that we take a known distance
say a 1 meter rod and we time how long
it takes for light which has a fixed
definite constant speed to travel that
length to construct our clock we place a
light source at one end of our rod like
a a torch or something and a mirror at
the other end we see a light ray will
propagate or pass from the light source
to the mirror its reflected goes back
down the rod and is detected somehow the
time taken to do this is our clocks
defined unit of time obviously this is a
pretty silly clock it won't be very much
ease in daily life but it keeps exact
precise time and we can work out what
that unit of time is it's the length of
the rod twice so 2 meters divided by the
speed of light so 2 over C now let's say
that both me and you own identical
models of this clock so we sit on a
bench together we observe each other's
clocks and we say that
yeah they keep exactly at the same time
both of our clocks in other words have
exactly the same unit of time I then sit
with my clock on a bench on a station
platform and I watch as you get onto a
train and the train moves past me I look
at my clock and it has exactly the same
unit of time you look at your clock and
it still has exactly the same unit of
time now this is my things get
interesting though let's say that I
wanted to work out your clocks unit of
time if you recall we defined a clocks
unit of time as the time taken for a ray
of light to get one end of the rod to
the other and back down again the
problem now is though that your clock or
your rod is moving past me
so if we trace out the path that a ray
of light takes it's no longer vertical
it's a diagonal if this is difficult to
imagine think of a person chucking a
tennis ball in the air whilst sat on a
train which is moving to them the tennis
ball is moving up and down no problem
but suddenly he's outside of the Train
that ball traces out a parabolic
trajectory going back to our light
clocks
this is where the crucial part comes in
because the thing about the speed of
light is that it's a constant but not
any old constant as can be worked out
from the equations which describe light
which is actually an oscillation of
electric and magnetic fields the speed
of light relative to you is constant no
matter how fast you're moving so if you
were to turn on a torch and measure how
fast the light is streaming away from
you you would find the speed of light
however if you were then to mount that
torch on something and get in a car and
drive away from the torture 100 miles an
hour and measure how fast the rays of
light were streaming away from you then
you still find the speed of light
exactly the speed of light relative to
you is always constant and what this
means for you and your clock on the
train is bizarre because the light is
moving exactly the same speed relative
to me as it always has done but now all
the light has to travel further because
of these diagonal paths your clock scene
at a time is longer than my clock
xenotime using basic algebra and
Pythagoras's rule we can establish
exactly how much further it has to
travel and so exactly how much slower
your clock is running we conclude then
because your clock which is identical to
mine clock now has a longer unit of time
than my station clock the time itself is
running slower for you on the moving
train than it is for me in other words
for any moving object time as perceived
on that object is slower than it is for
a stationary object we can see exactly
how much slower and we find that most of
the time it makes narrows down at no
difference because look we're dividing
the speed of our object which in this
case was our train by the speed of light
squared and the speed of light in case
you haven't noticed it's a really really
large number and so we're multiplying
our original unit of time for our clock
to oversee by this factor which is
almost exactly 1 but if we allow fee to
get really really large like really
quite close to the speed of light this
factor gets big like really really
really big so this process is a real
process it has been observed it's been
scientifically proven by experiments to
occur but in our everyday lives because
we typically don't move around anywhere
near the speed of light we just don't
notice it going back to our original
problem though we could ask exactly the
same question in Reverse let's say that
you on the train see me go past on the
platform and want to work out my clocks
unit of time because I've ever had that
experience where you're sat on a train
in a platform and there's another train
next to you and something moves and you
can't tell for a second whether it's
your train moving or the train next to
you moving if you didn't have any other
forms of reference or any form of
friction you genuinely wouldn't be able
to tell it would be impossible to tell
the laws of physics are exactly the same
in moving reference frames as they are
in stationary reference frames so we can
ask let's say that you're sat on a train
you think you're stationary but the
platform somewhat bizarrely is hurtling
past you you might then think that my
clock is running slow compared to your
clock which has kept the same time all
along what we find then is that the only
motion any speeds which are important to
this problem are those speeds which are
relative my speed relative to you the
Train speed relative to me as such this
all comes under
special relativity this is a physical
phenomenon called time dilation and it's
one of many physical phenomena which
occur in Einstein's theory of special
relativity I'm not going to talk any
more about the subject in this video
because apparently it's long enough
already however if you'd like to learn
more about things like length
contraction mass increase the twins not
actually a paradox then I highly
recommend you check out Richard
Feynman's
six easy pieces where there's a chapter
about relativity and if you'd like that
then also his six not so easy pieces
where he starts to talk about general
relativity on the other hand if you
would like a more mathematical treatment
of special relativity I cannot recommend
highly enough Rindler an introduction to
special relativity and once you've got a
little bit past that relativity his
seminal textbook on the subject I hope
this video was interesting because to me
this is one of the coolest things in
physics I owe this thought experiment to
Richard Feynman by the way I can't claim
to account this myself however if you
liked me doing this kind of video please
do like and comment and I would love to
do more of this kind of thing you go
Glen Coco